yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be explaining
everything you need to know about the
ending to venom and how the various
symbiotes in the movie set up future
sequels Plus keep watching to the end
where I'll reveal some sneaky Easter
eggs and little details you might have
missed in the post-credits and the
details of my new venom giveaways in
case you hadn't already guessed of
course I'll be talking spoilers so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet
at the end of the film venom defeats
Drake and riot by sabotaging their
rocket launch causing it to explode and
venom initially appears to perish during
the flaming fallout and says goodbye
Eddie Eddie later has a reunion with an
who believes he's free of the symbiote
but it's revealed that venom is still
alive and they're talking to Eddie in
his head Eddie clearly wants to get back
together with her and venom chips in you
belong with us Annie a hint that we'll
see she venom again in the potential
sequel and I'll talk more about and she
venom shortly Eddie decides to keep
Venom's existence a secret from Anne for
the moment and this scene reminded me of
the end of the first tobey maguire
spider-man movie where Peter Parker
hides his feelings from Mary Jane
although they eventually got together in
the next movie so what's the future for
venom and its fellow symbiotes well the
ending sets up how Eddie and venom will
interact with each other going forward
earlier in the movie we saw that often
the symbiotes will eat their human hosts
from the inside which seems to be why
they keep traveling from planet to
planet devouring their hosts until there
aren't any left venom is a bit different
from his fellow symbiotes and he gains
an appreciation for earth after he
climbs up the skyscraper looks out over
the city in a rather Spider Man esque
moment although venom started off by
forcing his host Eddie to do whatever
venom wanted by the end of the movie
Eddie has found he can control venom
somewhat and quiet him down Eddie also
decides to teach venom about right and
wrong and how he can't eat or hurt good
people
venom needs to eat though of course
otherwise he'll end up eating Eddie's
insides and we discover venom has a
taste for tater tots and chocolate when
they go to the store for food which
leads the scene where venom eats the
thug who's been shaking down mrs. Chen I
guess this means that Eddie will have to
keep hunting down bad guys as a way to
keep Venom's hunger at bay as for Anne's
future there's a big hint to that in the
scene where we discover she's bonded
with the Venom symbiote
and has become she venom she saved Eddie
as he's about to be killed by Drake's
henchmen then makes out with him at
which point venom flips back from her to
Eddie
Venom's reply of not today when she
demands to join the fight against riots
is a tease that she venom will be back
for a much bigger part in a possible
venom sequel and of course and did end
up fighting ugly as she put it when she
disables riot temporarily joined the
rocket launch sequence by turning up the
loudspeakers the venom sequel is also
going to have an even more powerful
villain than riot which I'll explain
next and I think Eddie and venom will
likely need and she venom powers against
him okay so Venom's next villain is set
up in the first post credits scene where
we see Eddie making his way to San
Quentin prison as he mentioned
previously to Anne he's got a job
reporting again and has what he calls
the interview of a lifetime with serial
killer Cletus Kasady in this scene we
finally meet Woody Harrelson who said
that his tiny role in this film sets him
up for a much bigger part in a venom
sequel the prison guard calls Cassidy
read a little reference to the villains
red hair and the red and black color of
the carnage symbiote which bonds with
Cassidy in the comics as Cassidy talks
to Eddie he threatens that when he gets
out of prison they'll be carnage a very
on-the-nose nod to the fact we'll be
seeing Cassidy become a host for the
carnage symbiote in the next movie in
the comics Eddie Brock and Cletus Kasady
end up sharing time in prison together
something the movie alludes to by the
fact that the imprisoned Cassidy are
specifically for Eddie to interview him
in the books Cassidy became carnage when
Eddie's pregnant symbiote gave birth and
the sport attached itself decluttr in
the film Eddie told venom to keep quiet
during the visit and I didn't see any
hint of the symbiote leaking out during
what we saw of Eddie's time there so
unless Cassidy has already been exposed
to a symbiote off screen
how will he end up as carnage well we
need to recap what symbiotes are still
left by the end the venom movie and how
Cassidy will be exposed to one the life
foundation extracted four distinct
symbiote samples from the comet there
was the black one venom who currently
inhabits Eddie
there was a blue one and a yellow one
and each of those died in the movie when
their hosts died one of which was Jenny
slates character dr. doris Cerf the
fourth sample was riot the symbiote
which escaped after the life foundations
spacecraft crashed in Malaysia riot
hopped around from host to host passing
from the EMT technician to the old woman
in the market then to the little girl at
the airport and finally on to Drake but
riot died together we Drake during the
rocket explosion remember there are just
two things which can kill a symbiote
fire and a sustained sound above a
certain frequency what's even more
important to recall though is that there
are millions of other symbiote still on
that comet that's presumably passing
through or near our solar system and
debris that breaks off from comets often
ends up as meteorites when they fall
into the Earth's atmosphere so what if a
red symbiote fell to earth via a meteor
it might even crash land in San Quentin
prison and help cletus kasady escape by
the way in the comics carnage is such a
powerful villain that venom is typically
teamed up with spider-man and the
Fantastic Four to combat the evil
symbiote at the moment Sony's deal with
Marvel Studios means spider-man can only
appear in the MCU not any of Sony's
current films however after Avengers 4
and spider-man far from home Tom
Hollands Peter Park all have appeared in
five MCU movies and it's possible that
Sony could pull spider-man back into
their own Marvel Universe to appear in a
venom sequel bonus Easter Egg time now
the way that Cassidy writes welcome Eddy
and blood inside his cage is a little
hat tip to how his character leaves the
phrase carnage rules in various places
in the comics if you didn't manage to
stay all the way through the very long
and pretty slow-moving credits he
probably missed the second end credits
scene which was a tease for Sony's
animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie the scene begins with
a comic-book pop up graphic meanwhile in
another universe indicating that the
animated movie exists in a different
reality - the venom movie what we see
next is not a trailer but a full-length
scene the animation on show looks
fantastic however it doesn't have any
impact on venom or any future venom
sequel so it feels a little disconnected
as it's basically just an extended
advert of course Marvel has simply shown
scenes from upcoming movies as
post-credit scenes however they do all
exist within the same universe so it
doesn't feel quite as odd now if you
enjoyed venom what was your favorite
moment in the movie or if you didn't
like it let me know why in the comments
below for a chance to win an awesome
venom Funko pop just make sure you're a
subscriber and leave me a comment about
the movie the winner of my Captain
Marvel Funko pop is on screen now and if
you're the winner message me via email
to claim the prize tap left to watch my
marvel playlist or tap write for another
video you're sure to LIKE and if you
enjoyed this video I really appreciate a
thumbs up and a share thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK a
movie lovers